aeryn aeryn aeryn what were you thinking
running off in the middle of the night
and taking your daughter out of the ALDC
that's just unacceptable no one runs
away from Abby you should know that by
now
subpoenas got a lot of talent and she
was on her way to becoming the best
dancer on Abby's team things were going
so good so why did you guys split we
need some answers
Erin say it ain't so Erin and Savannah
have ditched the ALDC and probably
aren't coming back
none of this makes any sense people
would kill to get their daughters a spot
on Abby's team wait does this mean
Abby's going to cast a new dancer keep
watching to find out
[Music]
you might be wondering why savanna and
her mom Erin chose to leave the ALDC
without so much as a warning fans were
stunned when Erin and Savannah didn't
show up to pyramid day and they weren't
the only ones the other moms couldn't
believe that Erin had abandoned the
group especially since Savannah had been
delivering some pretty stellar
performances there isn't just one reason
why Erin and Savannah chose to run off
but rather a collection of reasons the
first and most obvious one being that
Abby Lee Miller had recently announced
that
Eliana and Yolanda were making a
comeback Erin voiced her concerns when
Abby broke the news to this group she
also pointed out that bringing Yolanda
back wasn't beneficial to the game after
all she did choke out Stacy Erin took
things a step further by saying that
Yolanda has a tendency of being
obsessive and critical with other
people's children she topped off her
rant by saying that Savannah had never
been able to beat Ellie before which is
a common Abby didn't seem delight
regardless Abby didn't really
acknowledge any of her concerns
something we couldn't help but notice is
that during her one-on-one time with the
camera Abby said that should have kept
your mouth shut
was that a threat did Erin's outburst
rub Abby the wrong way if so she could
have had a hand in Erin leaving the show
in season 8 episode 7 Abby quickly
realized that Savannah and Erin were
nowhere to be found
and that's when Ann chimed in and when
Abby asked Ian if she'd meant good for
her or good for her kid and replied that
Erin had chosen to leave for her own
benefit not Savannah's Michelle took
things a step further by saying that
Erin didn't want Savannah to lose to
Eliana but when you think about it that
just doesn't make any sense as a be
pointed out everyone is on the same team
sure there can be some rivalries from
time to time but it's all in good fun
Stacey was obviously upset with Erin's
decision stating that
she could be there Aaron could be there
too after all Stacy's the one who got
choked by Yolanda not Aaron to make
matters worse it was Pyramid daya at the
ALDC and Savannah managed to score the
top spot Savannah was an amazing dancer
and arguably on her way to being Abby's
number one girl but when it comes down
to it we aren't exactly convinced that
Aaron in Savannah ran off in the middle
of the night because of Yolanda and
Eliana's returned it just doesn't check
out and we're not the only ones who
think so some fans believe that Savannah
was never planning to be part of the
ALDC for the entire eighth season they
pointed out that Savannah is a part of
the radix group and could potentially be
touring for the remainder of the season
in the end Savannah might have had prior
engagements to fulfill but instead of
telling the truth the show's producer
chose to spice things up a bit by
pretending that Aaron in Savannah ran
off in the middle of the night some fans
are convinced that Eliana and Savannah
were splitting their time up they were
never supposed to be part of the ALDC at
the same time instead they were meant to
replace each other and we've got the
facts to prove it season 8 episode 7 was
filmed on March 16 2019 but if you take
a look at Savannah's Instagram page
you'll see that Savannah posted a video
of her dancing at the radix dance
convention on March 18th 2019 that's
just two days after her spontaneous
disappearance on Dance Moms so in the
end it's clear that Eliana was meant to
replace Savannah but the producers added
some scripted moments to enhance the
show's shock factor Abby made it look
like Erin was ruining Savannah's career
by pulling her out of the ALDC but that
just wasn't true
although some fans remain hopeful that
Savannah will return before the end of
the season that might not be the case
however it's very possible that Brady
Farrar will make his big comeback once
the group gets their act together
although Abby did send him home her
decision wasn't set in stone
she just wanted the girls to step things
up and stop leaning on the star of the
show for support
although Savannah and Ileana did have an
on-screen rivalry Savannah isn't one to
shy away from good old competition and
sure Yolanda might not be the nicest or
seen as dance mom out of the group but
Aaron could have totally stood her
ground what do you guys think with
Savannah and Aaron's midnight escape
totally scripted or did they secretly
make the choice to skip out on the ALDC
when they found out that Yolanda and
Ellie were coming back sound off in the
comments for more fun videos about the
dance moms cats subscribe to the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching see
you soon
[Music]